does refresh rate
matter yes um yes it does the question
is to what degree the widespread switch
to 144 Hertz was a revolutionary
Landmark moment in Esports culture not
to mention the gaming industry as a
whole so this is 60 HZ so already like I
could tell that I could aim like if it's
like this much movement it's not so bad
but the big whips are so bad it even
feels laggier like look at my FPS is
still high too and it still feels
this but as refresh rates began to
double and triple people started talking
about seeing some diminishing returns
the Step Up from 60 to 154 HZ is a huge
Improvement and while the change from
144 to 240 HZ is not as obvious it's
still very impressive but the returns
may not be as diminishing as you might
think I personally have been using a 360
HZ monitor for well over a year and I
got to say the difference between it and
240 htz is substantial but assus have
raised the bar even higher the homies
over at Republic of Gamers said hold my
beer and released a 540 HZ super monitor
that supposedly blows away the
competition but we needed to see it to
believe it and let me tell you we uh we
saw it this is crazy this is
nuts okay so first things first I just
want to very quickly thank our friends
over at assus for sponsoring this video
sending us their new Rog Swift Pro 540
HZ Monitor and the means to test it so
before we get into the monitor itself
and talk about how categorically
mindblowing it is let's just do a quick
run through as to what refresh rate
actually
is I have what do you mean I have to
explain it thought that's what the guy
knows what he's talking about is for
what do you mean he's only contractually
obligated to do one segment per video H
iy must think he's a real big shot if
he's just going to show up if and when
he pleases what's that what do you mean
he gets paid more than me refresh rate
is simply put the number of times per
second measured in hertz that a display
gets updated with new information that's
it it has nothing to do with color
resolution or brightness merely the
speed with which the stuff on screen
gets presented to you and when you're
immersed in a competitive multiplayer
experience be it a tactical shooter an
arena shooter a MOA even a battle royale
that's what you care about the question
is to what extent now I'm not going to
get into the technicalities of it all
since well we did that there's a whole
other crack dedicated to refresh rates
that you should totally consult if
you're trying to get a crash course but
the long and the short of it is that
everyone and their mother agrees that
144 Herz is vastly superior to 60 HZ and
that anyone who even remotely cares
about gaming should take the leap what
isn't as clear is whether it's worth
going any higher if you're not an actual
professional 144 and 240 does have a
difference but the difference is not
like huge I would say I would say 120 or
14 4 um 240 is more of a luxury if you
have the if you have the money and funds
for it go go ahead like it's definitely
a quality of life thing but um you won't
really notice that too big of a
performance increase from 240 and 120 in
fact some people have even reverted to a
lower refresh rate either because the
higher one didn't feel right because
their PC couldn't turn out enough frames
or both if you're a sweaty competitive
gamer your best option right now might
actually be a 240 HZ gaming monitor that
also means that if you are currently
gaming on a 240 HZ display I'd say that
360 HZ is not worth the upgrade
depending on what your current monitor
is like 240 HZ I'd say is really refined
and your FPS will be able to keep 240
whereas 360 is kind of like that's hard
first off to get 360 FPS constantly and
then it's also doesn't feel consistent
in my opinion I don't know how to
explain it but here's the thing back
then it was really easy to look at what
was then a really high refresh rate like
240 Herz and think it will just never
ever get any better than this nowadays
things have changed why acclamation to
be clear diminishing returns are real
but that hardly means that there is no
perceptible difference between higher
refresh rates or that the difference is
in a word negligible it's not like I
said I personally have been using a 360
Herz for well over a year and the jump
between it and 240 is absolutely
noticeable in fact whenever I switch
back to 240 I always find it way more
jarring than I anticipate Everything
feels slower when you've played on
something faster and let me tell you
faster is quickly becoming the norm it's
so hard dude I've been on 240 HZ for so
long swapping off is just going to be
wild and while I still wouldn't
recommend a 360 Hertz for the average
everyday Esports enjoyer mostly because
they're still really expensive that does
not mean that it's not a worthy
investment for the super sweaty EEG
Gamers out there which is exactly why
assus upped the ante meet rog's newest
craziest offering the pg248 QP it boasts
a
540 HZ refresh rate which makes it the
fastest consumer grade monitor on the
market now Asus reached out and sent us
one to test but first we had to sort out
the tiny little inconsequential detail
that was us not actually having a
computer that was powerful enough to run
it so again with the help of aus we
built one but I'll let that twirly
mustached turbo dork talk about that and
now the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about so before I get into it
yes Asus sent us the Rog Swift Pro
monitor or the company I don't get to
keep it but you are getting our honest
opinion here as many of you know I have
a pretty nasty personal rig that I built
a couple of years ago but when they came
to me and asked if I thought it could
handle 540 Hertz we would have need a
bigger boat the goal pumping out more
than 540 FPS in some of your favorite
Esports titles like CS2 valerant and
OverWatch 2 to get there we spared no
expense kiding this PC out with an Intel
I94 14900 KF an RTX 490 and 64 GB of
ddr5 RAM Overkill maybe a little a
little bit but I wanted to give this 540
HZ monitor the best possible chance at
impressing me we'll get back to the PC
in a minute but first let's talk a
little bit about the monitor that we're
plugging into it we've already talked
about why a higher refresh rate is good
for competitors and this is definitely
wicked fast but response time isn't
everything the Rog Swift pro has a TN
panel which fun fact of the day works by
applying very precise electric currents
to pneumatic Liquid Crystal molecules
how does that all work I don't know I'm
a computer scientist not a molecular
physicist cut me a little slack the
important thing for you to actually know
about TN panels is that while they are
fast they sacrifice viewing angles and
color accuracy in the process as someone
who makes video content for a Living
Color accuracy is pretty important to me
so this monitor is already fighting an
uphill battle if it wants to impress me
the viewing experience was definitely
better than I expected but my
expectations were pretty much zero
considering what I've experienced with
other high-end TN panels if your only
focus is playing single player highly
visual experiences you're probably
better off with a monitor that has an
OLED panel but we are worried about
competing so how did all of that sick
Hardware actually perform in Esports
titles well good like really good
Counterstrike was Counter Strike and was
a hellscape trying to get working
valerant was actually hitting around
1,000 frames at its peak and OverWatch
was very stable between four and 600 FPS
so our Hardware was definitely capable
of driving this monitor to its full
potential the question is can yours this
PC cost us somewhere in the neighborhood
of $7,000 Canadian doll R which is not
something that your average gamer is
using a computer using the most popular
parts from the steam Hardware survey is
pretty unlikely to get a high enough
frame rate in any of these games to
really get any use out of that refresh
rate even at 1080p which yeah did we
mention it's a 1080p monitor that's
actually not that big a deal for a lot
of people clearly but it might be a deal
breaker for some of you maybe not
everyone has the kind of Hardware that
can power this Beast of a monitor but if
you can afford it odds are pretty good
you've got the hardware that can drive
this thing as someone who's only been
using 144 Hertz for the last couple of
years this was a wild jump and
smoothness being able to see targets
faster with reduced motion blur while
you're turning quickly is a pretty
obvious benefit for a serious comp edor
but for me well there's only so much you
can do for a former console Scrub but
you aren't here for what I think so now
with my hard work building the computer
all done I sat down everyone's favorite
CS junkie so he could tell us how pretty
the pictures were and that was the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about so yeah do you need a 540 HZ
monitor I mean no more than you need a
McLaren or a Rolex but that doesn't mean
that it isn't insanely cool the simple
fact is that the Rog Swift Pro offers
the fastest crispiest gaming experience
I have ever had the motion blur
reduction is second to none and based on
our time with the monitor it is super
smooth okay I did not think you could
really get smoother than 360 but this is
absolute lunacy it's just crazy like the
smoothness which with everything lives
moves the map itself like just the way
the world feels rendered is just crazy
like it's soing smooth now while the
monitor is super
impressive it's also a top-of-the line
luxury
$899 for a monitor is a lot but if you
want the best of the best it's worth it
540 HZ was a perception altering
experience and I can absolutely
understand someone wanting to spend big
bucks to integrate it into their normal
everyday setup if that sounds like you I
would totally recommend springing for
the Asus assuming of course that your
computer can handle it which is sort of
a big assumption even a badass rig like
hours struggled to get newer less
optimized titles like CS2 to run at a
consistent 6 or 700 frames so if you're
PC can't do that and you're still
interested in flexing a sick display I'd
probably recommend rog's Swift OLED pg27
a qdm it's 1440p 240 HZ and has a
beautiful OLED panel if you're already
on 240 HZ I probably just wait until the
540 HZ and the hardware needed to run it
becomes a little more accessible I love
360 HZ and I would never go back but I
do not think the difference between it
and 240 is substantial enough to justify
jumping a single interval the jump from
60 to 144 was the highest the jump from
144 to 240 I would say was probably the
second highest the jump from 240 to 360
I I say I would I think was honestly
just as pronounced as as the jump from
144 to 240 jumping from 360 to 540 feels
just as pronounced as jumping from 240
to 360 I do really notice this but that
doesn't answer the question as to
whether or not Pros will switch to it
and the answer I think is sort of
inevitably yes it just isn't clear when
right now the majority of top
Counterstrike competitors have switched
360 Herz but there are a few outliers
who are still doing fine on 240 so the
idea that someone's going to snap their
fingers and everyone's suddenly going to
flock to 540 does seem sort of
unrealistic let's go into the new
settings first uh what do we have here
43 we go 1280 960 with two 240 gears
that's important maybe you guys don't
have to at home but uh I play like this
but that's not to say that players
aren't switching or that the industry
and infrastructure that is Esports isn't
giving them cause to 240 HZ became the
standard at every ESL csgo event way
back in March 2022 and 360 Herz started
becoming the standard for both the VCT
and LEC about Midway through 2023 Pros
are switching and what's really
interesting is that it seems like
they're switching from 240 to 360 faster
than they did from 144 to 240 now I'm
not saying you need to run out tomorrow
and jack up your refresh rate to
suddenly become great at the games you
love what I am saying is that the
revolution isn't just coming it's here
this myth that you can't even really
tell the difference Beyond 144 Hertz is
definitely being put to bed and the
industry standards are finally starting
to rise as fast as the technology is
advancing it's only a matter of time
before crazy batshit rigs like the one
we tested today become as accessible as
the stuff we all use at home High
refresh rates are the way of the future
and as someone who's seen the future I
can tell you it's
sick which makes it yes the fastest
monitor on the market better to just
specifically say consumer monitor cuz
like I'm sure that there's like 7,000 HZ
monitor in like a lab and yeah we could
say what makes it the fastest consumer
grade monitor so I'm sure this other
monitor is like technically on the
market in CL not if if you're if you're
NASA it's on the Market's going to be in
the com like actually actually my uncle
works at CERN